une quarantaine d'économistes et de
chercheurs en économie signent une
lettre qui remet en question la
pertinence du projet gnl québec sur le
plan écologique mais aussi sur le plan
économique des économistes de plusieurs
universités dont notre temps notre
invité ce soir jérôme dupras professeur
à l'université du québec en outaouais
titulaire de la chaire de recherche du
canada en économie écologique bonsoir
bonsoir soir jérôme dupras vous
contestez la prétention de base du
promoteur de gène et gnl québec qui est
celle que le gaz transporté va remplacer
pourrait remplacer parce qu'il médecin
quand même imparfait pourrait remplacer
des énergies fossiles qu'est ce qui vous
permet de dire ça mais en se basant sur
ce que dit l agence canadienne
d'évaluation environnementale des
projections ne sont pas basés sur des
données probantes
donc c'est vraiment des estimations on
projette sur et potentiellement
remplacement le promoteur dit qu'on peut
remplacer 60 % des gens de d'énergie
fossile donc déjà 40% qui est admis même
par leurs promoteurs comme étant une
additionally t de gaz à effet de serre
et sur soie sur 60 % ont dit qu'ils
seraient dirigés vers l'europe et la
chine en remplacement d'énergie plus
sales donc du charbon ou du charbon par
exemple quand on prend le contexte
international on voit que une
augmentation de ce type d' usine de
liquéfaction le deux tiers et terre et
en amérique du nord dont deux déjà là on
peut penser que rue89 a augmenté à
l'entrée en fonction de l' usine
en 2025 donc plus d'offres et l'agencé
internationale l'énergie qui claudique y
aura une croissance très faible pour ce
type de produit en europe donc est
vraiment ici une demande qui serait pas
très grandissante avec une offre qui
décuple est donc on a on a tous à croire
que ce sera peut-être pas un
remplacement tel qu'espéré
ce sera peut-être pas un remplacement
mais ce sera peut-être en remplacement
on n'a pas la preuve d'un côté comme de
l'autre que ce gaz naturel va remplacer
du charbon mais si on réduit la
consommation de charbon dans plusieurs
pays en asie notamment
est ce qu'on doit pas profiter de
l'occasion pour avoir un meilleur
produit moins polluants qui émettent
moins de gaz à effet de serre et de
participer à cela
oui c'est vrai à certains égards mais
faut toujours regarder le portrait large
le portrait lâcheté qu'il est stipulé
par les experts du climat nous dit que
pour rester dans une zone un peu
confortable sur un point 5 degrés
celsius on a une fenêtre de dix ans pour
agir donc tout à tout est question de la
rapidité de la transition énergétique
qu'on soit capable de réaliser donc la
rapidité basé sur
un transvasement vers des énergies
fossiles moins polluante mais ça nous
amène à un horizon qui est beaucoup plus
loin que ce disant c'est pas assez
rapide c'est ce que vous dit exactement
donc des options de le fait qu'ils sont
beaucoup plus rapides par exemple ce
qu'on va construire comme comme gazoducs
et comme usine de liquéfaction c'est une
infrastructure ce sont des
infrastructures qui sont là pour 40 ou
50 ans donc c'est comme si on se
structure est le développement de la
région de l'état québécois de la nation
base est toujours sur le fossile au
tournant des années 2050 donc on sait
que ça c'est beaucoup trop lent par
rapport à l'urgence climatique et
l'urgence de l'action nécessaire mais
j'insiste quand même
est ce que il n'est pas préférable
d'avoir d'avoir un geste de transition
en admettant que le gaz naturel est une
énergie de transition je sais que
beaucoup de gens se posaient cela mais
si on admet ça est ce qu'on n'est pas
dans un geste de transition avec
d'autres énergies qui ré plus rapidement
des énergies véritablement renouvelable
et propre
oui c'est un geste de transition mais
sans avoir considéré les autres options
donc ici on a regardé de façon très
cadrée et même le ministre charest de
ministres d'environnement on dit que
dans la consultation du bape qui
démarrera au début de l'an 2020 on
prendrait pas en compte l'amont et
l'aval de la demande énergétique
donc c'est vraiment si ici on vient
cadrer le projet ce sont nous les
français mesurent sa production mais
sans comprendre la dynamique mondiale de
l'énergie donc c'est tout à fait passer
à côté de la situation réelle
et vous pensez que si tout le projet
dans son ensemble était analysée par un
bureau d'audiences publiques ou par une
instance fédérale environnementale que
ce projet serait beaucoup plus émetteurs
de gaz à effet de serre déjà une lettre
était signée par 150 scientifiques
quelques mois qui disait que des
incertitudes énormes au niveau de la
de la fracturation qu'on va chercher ce
gaz il ya des émissions de méthane qu'on
epoca de quantifier mais on sait
qu'elles sont importantes et le méthane
est un gaz à effet de serre 20 fois plus
puissant que le co2 donc cette partisane
n'est pas prise en compte l'analyse de
cycle de vie de toute cette transmission
au delà du gaz qui sera transférée dans
la production
on était à 8 millions de
8 mégatonnes d'équivalent co2 qui sont
émises donc on regarde pas non plus ce
bout là le promoteur dit quand même qui
pourrait y avoir une réduction de 28
millions de tonnes de co2 par année en
tenant compte du cycle de vie complet du
gaz naturel ça représente 6 millions de
voitures avec l'objectif la cible qui
est celle de remplacer des énergies
fossiles
vous contestez ce chef de 28 millions de
tonnes oui mais en fait c'est une
situation idéale qui serait unique où
tout convergeait vers ça et quand on
regarde les données de l'agencé
internationale énergétique l' agence
canadienne d'évaluation environnementale
personnes nous dit que ça s'en va dans
cette direction là donc les
scientifiques nous disent que 80% des
ressources fossiles doivent rester sous
terre on est dans une situation où on en
extrait où on n'a pas besoin de ces
emplois là parce qu'on est en situation
de pénurie de main d'oeuvre au
saguenay-lac-saint-jean donc la moitié
des corps de métier en construction sont
en pénurie des arrêts de production chez
rio tinto parce qu'on manque d'emplois
donc c'est pas non plus un argument est
ce qu'on arrête de faire des projets de
développer des emplois parce qu'on est
en rareté de main-d'oeuvre pas du tout
mon fait des projets structurants qui
sont conciliants avec une réelle urgence
climatique d'un côté qui sont là pour
des décennies à venir et qui pourront
maintenir des emplois dans ces filières
donc si on développe le gaz naturel
liquéfié qu'on voit que le marché
s'effondre dans 20 30 ans qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec ses infrastructures avec
la demande d'emploi dans ce secteur là
pour maintenir l'industrie
industrie en route donc l'idée c'est de
dire il n'y a pas d'urgence sur ces
emplois là il n'y a pas d'urgence
mise à part pour sortir les ressources
fossiles de glace canadien ce qui est
pas nécessairement notre notre notre
rôle ici on verra le bape de toute façon
en 2020 également jérôme dupras merci
merci à vous